[Laughter]
Jesus your
finger what just
[Music]
happened I'm of Switzerland and there's
a big Festival going
on everyone has the day off they're all
Gathering to have a good time to
celebrate
[Music]
guns it's a shooting competition for
teenagers and they've been doing this
for hundreds of
years he used to just be boys but now
it's boys and girls and the winner is
deemed the king or queen of
shooting
[Music]
Switzerland is a peaceful neutral
country and yet it is full of
guns the government gives its citizens
guns and trains them how to shoot every
village is required to have access to a
shooting range we have almost as many
guns per head or per person here as as
in America back home in the United
States we also have a lot of guns but
the culture around guns is a little
different the right of the people to
keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed the country of Switzerland
proves that there's no need for more gun
rules gun is the number one cause of
death among children in the United
States yet we don't have the will to
stop Switzerland has the lowest crime
rate in Europe that's all we have at
this point God in our guns I really want
to get to the bottom of this this gun
culture thing why these two countries
have such vastly different relationships
with guns so I delved deep deeper than I
usually delve and found myself digging
through old literature from Scottish
political philosophers and looking into
the Constitutional archives talking to
Second Amendment experts talking to
military historians from Switzerland and
it's finally all clicked for me and I
want to share that with you so buckle up
for what is going to be a wild ride
through history and an adventure through
[Applause]
Switzerland
[Music]
so as a side note to this story I've
been finding a lot of bunkers in
Switzerland which if you all remember a
year ago from right now I published a
video about all of the bunkers hiding in
Switzerland and now that I'm here again
I find find myself stumbling upon more
and more bunkers anyway I also want to
tell you that my trip here to
Switzerland and my ability to go around
and shoot at shooting ranges and spend
months diving into Swiss history is made
possible because of our generous
sponsors who come back month after month
to support our journalism better help
who is the sponsor of today's video is a
platform that is making therapy more
accessible to people normally what you
do when you want a therapist is you like
call around you see if like a therapist
has availability here in the United
States you like check to see if like
your insurance works with that
therapist you wait a few weeks you
schedule back and forth over the phone
and then maybe you see a therapist and
if they're not a good fit like good luck
you have to do it again with better help
you basically sign up you fill out a
survey the survey then matches you with
somebody in their giant Network they
have a huge Network of like like tens of
thousands of like licensed therapists
that will connect you with one that they
think is a good fit for you and you can
start communicating with them right away
you can talk by phone you can talk by
video chat or you can just do like
chatting back and forth over a text
message you get to decide that if you
don't like your therapist you can change
your therapist I went to therapy not
because I had a clinical diagnosis like
depression or anxiety but because I'm a
human who has stressful things in my
life and has a lot of inner voices
telling me how I should think about
myself and some of those voices aren't
very nice and I wanted to understand my
inner self and understand my mind and
start to retrain it that's what therapy
is and it has changed my life in huge
ways so I'm really grateful that
betterhelp is making therapy more
accessible to people via the Internet
there's a link in the description of
this video it is betterhelp.com Johny
Harris when you click the link it tells
betterhelp that this ad is working and
it supports this Channel and if you want
to sign up for better help you get 10%
off your first month so you can try it
out at a discount see if it works for
you and yeah you can give therapy a try
let's get back to the video I'm in
beautiful Switzerland here shooting guns
and learning a lot about Firearms let's
go
there's the shooting range and the
targets are on this side oh yeah there's
the targets oh I hear them holy smoke so
they're literally shooting over the road
right
there God there people just jeez there
are bullets flying over our head right
now oh my
God that a that is such a weird feeling
headed to a shooting competition right
now at this shooting range surrounded by
beautiful Swiss mountains the sound of
these guns my God it's like a war zone
morning oh wow this but it's only six
rounds yeah but it's single loaded so
you always have to you always have to
[__] it yeah then you can make the ring
wider yeah and smaller and you can
[Music]
even as I'm standing here you realize
like like the cars are right there you
could easily shoot them if you wanted to
if you were standing up like I knew that
this existed I I saw the Tom Scott video
a few months ago I thought it was like
there was one crazy shooting range in
swizerland that goes over a road I
didn't realize it was
common it's a friendly competition it's
all very wholesome you see these young
kids that are like keeping score
tabulating all of the results I've been
hanging out with the president of one of
these shooting clubs trying to
understand a little bit better about
what this event and things like this
represent for these communities the
military law um tells all the villages
that they need to provide a shooting
range or possibility to shoot after a
while of observing this competition they
told me that it was my turn to shoot but
first I needed to learn how to use one
of these
guns we got the ammo military provided
at a discount just try again mhm so so
you're right hand right-handed yep I'm
right-handed is there a telescope in
there like how am I seeing that far down
no there's no telescope there's no
telescope oh that's what makes it you're
not allowed to use any any SES any
Optics uh at any competitions it's
within okay so you're going to make sure
I don't hit any of these cars yeah now
you're not you're not able to see any
cars anymore nope no more cars so no
more cars no more problems about that
yes maybe yeah move a little bit further
yeah you're ready yeah I think I'm ready
yep now it's loaded it's ready to shoot
oh my God okay Target 19 Target 19 here
we
go very slow now now you pulled all the
way through oh I did yes ex yes yes I
forgot about that that's why normally we
train how that works but you hit the
target I hit the target that's good okay
you actually hit the
target that's good oh there we go now we
saw it I'm getting
as I shot in my first gun competition I
was surprised that my instructor kept
telling me to relax to breathe to turn
inward exactly yeah that felt way more
relaxed oh there we go there we go wow I
turned inward relaxed and I hit the 10
yeah Sharpshooter over
here wow this is addictive I I
definitely see like I'm like I could do
this all day so this is like relax
relaxing or calming down for me
sometimes I I feel like going into
another world do you turn your focus
from focusing outside you're focusing
inside wow this is fun objectively this
is just fun and it's beautiful and look
looking at the Swiss
Countryside it's
great my experience with guns as a kid I
would go out into the forest and like
blow up like like glass bottles with
shotguns that's what what I think
America is all
[Music]
about wow that was awesome I kind of
want to shoot again I never thought i'
say like I'm not a gun person but I'm
like I kind of want to like shoot more
like this is so fun I was struck by how
peaceful and celebratory and wholesome
this all was so much different than the
way guns are presented in the USA so how
did we get
here
[Music]
the story of Switzerland starts here
well actually down there at that Lake in
a little Green Valley where a group of
people came together and made a promise
to each other 700 years ago and with
that promise came a
myth the hero's name was William Tell
and Legend has it that one day he
refused to bow down to the king's local
leader it was a daring Act of disrespect
so as punishment the overlord forced him
to shoot an apple off his own son's head
tell aimed his crossbow carefully and
released he made the perfect shot he
continued to defy the ruler and
eventually inspired the tribes in this
region to launch a rebellion tell
eventually shot the ruler dead and the
rebels would go on to win their
independence B standing together to
start the Confederacy that would become
Switzerland they first made an agreement
that they would protect one another but
instead of forming a full-time standing
army run by a king they would arm and
Train Ordinary People to fight so not an
army at all but rather a
[Music]
militia I'm now going into a shooting
range that is in the mountain a Dugout
bunker very
Swiss it feels like the old bunker days
exploring a bunker but I'm in a shooting
range mind blowingly big it's like a
it's like a maze in the mountain with
just a bunch of
rooms
shooting okay so now I'm fully loaded
safy off I'm going to take safety off
yeah if you on the target if you are on
the Target and you want to shoot you can
take the safety off or not
[Music]
okay shooting in the bunker is a
completely different experience like you
feel the vibration of your entire body
cuz the echo is so extreme I'm getting
better at shooting
[Music]
oh my God oh my God oh yeah stra
in you never shot before right no two
days ago I
started
so back to 1600's Europe where
Switzerland remained this one peaceful
Confederacy protected by its citizen
militia meanwhile in the rest of Europe
greedy kings were using their huge
standing armies to conquer one another
while Switzerland stood by training its
citizens in the ways of
War Swiss citizens got so good at
fighting that the Pope hired them as his
personal protectors other Empires would
even hire Swiss soldiers to fight their
own Wars but Switzerland itself remained
almost entirely out of these conflicts
on the continent eventually European
thinkers start to notice this peculiar
Alpine Confederacy Switzerland this
place that trains their citizens to
fight and miraculously showed that you
can have a republic even in Europe a sea
of monarchy and
kings
I've been reading a lot of like old
European political literature and you
start to see this phrase pop up to
describe how Switzerland defends itself
using a well-regulated
militia I saw this term a lot when I was
looking through this old
literature around 1610 this British
Diplomat goes to Switzerland and gaws at
their well-regulated militia how they
can overturn their government AT
Pleasure because they all know how to
fight by the way back in like the 1600s
well-regulated militia meant like a well
organized or efficiently run militia not
like regulated in the way that we think
of it today but yeah the idea was if you
arm everyone in your society and you
train them that's actually the key to
the best defense and the best
preservation of freedom for the people
not just the
king this idea of a well-regulated
militia spread across the ocean to a
group of British intellectuals who were
secretly conspiring to overthrow their
own
King in 1776 they declared independence
using their own well-regulated militia
to fight off a tyrannical King and his
standing army as they fought this war a
leader from Switzerland wrote to
Benjamin Franklin suggesting that this
new Rebel experiment called the United
States should become sister republics
with
Switzerland the Americans somehow won
this war and got to work designing their
new country
they sat down in a hot Church looking
building to draft the document that
would be the foundation of this
experiment a system free of
Kings the founders studied the political
systems of Greece and Rome they studied
the British Magna Carta Native American
confederacies European
philosophers but then there was John
Adams one of the founders who was kind
of obsessed with Switzerland at this
time he studied their system
and he was amazed at how their militia
worked how they required everyone to
have a gun and to have ammo and they
wouldn't let them get married unless
they did he wrote All About This In Like
A Treatise on different government
systems right before he wrote the
Constitution with his fellow co-founders
Switzerland was a model it was the
Republic that had resisted tyranny and
been able to stay free in a Europe full
of kings and when it came time to write
the actual Constitution you can see that
a militia was in grind in the
Constitution itself in the Constitution
the role of the militia is to protect
the government to protect the country
from Invasion or
[Music]
Insurrection and then after the
Constitution it became time to draft
that sacred list of the most fundamental
rights that would ensure that the
American project remained free and full
of Liberty the first of these 10
Amendments would be freedom of speech
and of expression assembly religion and
the Press press but right after that
they write the Second Amendment and it's
about the well-regulated militia being
vital being necessary for the security
of a free country so to have a militia
the people must have arms they must have
a right to have guns so now you have the
Constitution the Bill of Rights and the
Second Amendment and then a few years
later the well-regulated militia idea
got enshrined in law when one of the
first congresses passed a law that said
that every man doesn't just have the
right to have a gun but is required ired
to have a gun and ammo and must train to
use it so that the president could call
on its armed citizens as its mechanism
for defense this whole legal framework
was very clearly like yes you can have
guns but only if you are ready to use
them to defend our country from Invasion
or Insurrection and sure enough George
Washington had to actually use this
there was this rebellion in Pennsylvania
over taxes and George Washington called
up his armed citizens to March and Tamp
down on these Rebels and it told totally
worked the militia system was working
for this Young Nation to ensure its
freedoms with an armed citizenry
something Switzerland had been doing for
centuries guns started out as a symbol
of collective security as collective
defense armed citizens ready to stand up
to defend the country but needless to
say things kind of changed when it came
to guns in America so how we got from
that to this is the next part of this
video and in my mind it's the most
interesting version of this story
because it shows us how Switzerland and
the United States diverged so severely
from this militia culture okay but
before we get to that I want to show you
more about Switzerland Today show you
what it looks like when a country sticks
to an actual militia system as their
primary tool for National Defense
okay to better understand gun ownership
in Switzerland I visited a member of the
Swiss
Army hey hey how you doing nice to meet
you hey can I see your gun uh of
course that's why we I want to play some
where's Waldo where is the assault rifle
oh my gosh I already see you're so you
just have a gun in your corner here you
want to carry it want to carry it what's
interesting to me is like for you this
is like no big deal for me this is a
giant gun like this is like this is I
don't handle guns like I held a gun like
this for the first time like 2 days ago
for the very first time in my life no
way Yes actually I'm an American yeah
yeah about that's very uniche yes
Switzerland still has a militia every
able-body man in Switzerland is given a
uniform and a gun and required to join
the military so and this is in the this
is in the Constitution it's written
there that every male can be forced not
only forced to do military service but
also forced to make more so instead of
21 weeks I did 37 weeks and in total I
have to do like 450 days up until the
'90s you would go to jail if you refused
to do this now you just have to pay 3%
of your income if you don't I was also
very against the military and and I I
went reluctantly one of the first things
you do in this initial training is you
come to one of these clubs and you learn
to shoot it was kind of scary actually
because it's all like 18 to 20 year old
guys and just like oh yeah we're going
to go to shoot this gun now and it's
like here's ammunition here's here's
here's the rounds and now you do what
did you learn after the recruits
complete their training they return back
to their normal jobs to their normal
lives but they keep their firearm with
them in their home and then they're
required to come to one of these private
clubs every year to practice
shooting it's called the obligator so
you obligatory or M for people to shoot
this is my shooting book you every time
I shoot there is
uh there is like a little report
somebody has to sign it of course when
you go shooting and just take this out
but then it's just like this wow and you
go the public transport just like
that just walking around on the on the
train with your gun yeah really yeah
yeah so it's actually similar to what
the United States national defense
strategy looked in like the 1800s where
every able man had a gun and was
required to use it required to be ready
to defend the country from Invasion or
Insurrection part of this is also being
able to fight if it would be necessary
uh just to you know protect our country
and this uh you know
self-defense thinking is part of our you
know our people and and from Switzerland
what Switzerland doesn't have that we
have in the United States is a second
amendment an articulated unambiguous
right to have guns instead guns are
articulated mostly as a duty to protect
the country and then secondly comes the
privilege to use guns to compete with
them to own Guns Etc for them the duty
came
first we have a tradition of more of a
liberty tradition and there it's more of
a um a responsibility tradition
essentially everybody has to go so this
is kind of like one thing that unifies a
lot of the male population here and it's
just like you can meet a guy and if he
has done military service as well you
can talk for hours and hours and hours
on end and this to me makes all the
difference like these two different
purposes of guns in society whether they
are a right for individuals or the duty
of the collective I think this is a
major factor that divides these two gun
cultures if you could describe Swiss
shooting culture in three words what
would those words
be and this is where it all clicked for
me I had thought that Switzerland's gun
culture was the product of smart laws
and gun policies but being here it was
becoming clear that it was the militia
system that was at the root of all of
this the requirement for every man to
learn how to shoot as the main strategy
for Collective National Defense
turning guns into a symbol of community
and celebration the center of large
festivals all over the country where
Swiss Traditions are celebrated with
Firearms at the center like that teen
shooting competition in Zurich or this
important shooting Festival that takes
place at the foot of the Alps along a
beautiful Swiss Lake the place where the
founders of Switzerland formed their
Confederacy in
you have so many members of the
community coming out and participating
in them you're going to have fun the
shooting is fun they'll have music after
you're done shooting you can have some
beer or wine or and it's a family affair
and so they kept that
alive
[Music]
okay we're at yet another gun club and
once again this gun club has a Target
that goes right over the top of a
highway I'm here to continue to learn
what the deal is with Swiss gun culture
and to see if I can get a better score
than I did last time okay so this is the
gun we're shooting
today going to give it a go here oh
there's a kick there's a kick on this
one okay here it goes
[Music]
wow
jeez uh okay man the sound the sound
like Echoes Echoes through the
[Music]
valley
okay
hey beginner's luck
continues
wow oh oh here comes the score my score
card oh okay what do we have here also
only that
[Music]
this it's The Beginner's luck beginners
luck this is my scorecard here my Moosh
what's it called Moosh Moosh I got the
Moosh yes so 300 M away to think that
this bullet just traveled across the
valley over the cars and hit a a thing
that's this big is pretty satisfying so
while I'm sitting here shooting Bull's
eyes right below us not only are their
cars but there's a guy just mowing the
lawn like there's a guy mowing the lawn
right there under the shooting range
this place is at once super buttoned up
when it comes to guns and and seemingly
very relaxed but it's not relaxed as I
visit these gun clubs it's striking how
much the feel like a magnet for
Community a gathering place for the
community a collective activity and
competition that everyone in the
community can enjoy I'm so used to guns
being associated with danger and
Division and politics and fear but here
it just has such a different feel than
what I'm used to thank you so much I
really appreciate your time thank you
this is really
good it's been a really enlightening
experience visiting all these shooting
ranges and what it's taught me is that
guns here in Switzerland are a totally
different thing than they are in America
like they're a completely different
symbol they have a very different
purpose they have a very different
meaning and that's kind of surprising to
me because remember that the United
States was founded on a lot of the same
paradigms as Switzerland when it came to
having a militia and having firearms in
society as a form of collective defense
so to understand how these two gun
cultures so greatly diverge despite
having similar Roots you have to
understand what happens after the
Constitution after the second
amendment I have the right to protect my
family and
myself what do you think about American
Gun culture like what's the what's the
view Bonkers like the fact that
everybody has a gun in America it would
make me feel uneasy and I'm used to
being in the proximity of guns and a lot
of guns I don't know how you guys do it
and if he tries to take our guns he can
take them from our cold dead hands there
has been a shooting at a synagogue get
off my porch right now gun control all
it's going to do is take the guns out of
the people that obey the law three
people are killed in Jacksonville
Florida today after what appears to be a
racially motivated hate
crime so after its independence the US
quickly learned that while a militia is
great for defense deterrence and
neutrality it is not good for one thing
[Music]
Conquest beginning in the 19th century
the US expanded West very quickly they
fought other European colonists and
Native Americans for their land they
would eventually fight each other in a
civil war these kinds of operations were
too big for militias made up of everyday
citizens instead they needed to
establish and fund a centralized
professional standing army and this was
just the beginning by the time the 1900s
were rolled around the US had grown into
something that Switzerland never was and
probably never will be an expansionist
Empire using its sprawling permanent
military to wield influence around the
globe by the middle of the century it
would become the largest and most
powerful military to have ever
existed because the US had a huge
standing army it did away with a lot of
the original laws requiring people to
join the militia
and now without a duty to form a militia
to protect the country from Invasion and
Insurrection like the Constitution said
they were left with just the second half
of this amendment the right to bear arms
and how it should not be infringed guns
started to become more of a personal
tool a tool to pursue their American
Dream to hunt to protect their family to
exterminate it's more like the rbo style
it's not like I'm going shooting at the
Target you don't go shooting somewhere
in in in in the woods or in the forest
just don't do that you go to a shooting
range and you get part of the community
and then your goal is not just to you
know shoot wherever there is so your
goal is to get better yeah and your goal
is not just to shoot around guns
continued to take on a more personal
symbol in the 60s and70s when more and
more Americans were losing trust in
their government this was also right at
the time when crime was skyrocketing in
America
without this Duty for Collective defense
guns became more and more a symbol of
personal defense from all of this crime
personal Liberty and a symbol of this
growing anti-government sentiment and as
a result the number of guns in America
soared the NRA which remember after the
Civil War started as a largely
non-political group that was meant to
just help Americans be more responsible
and better marksmen they got taken over
in the 70s by a group of hardliners who
wanted to change the agenda of the NRA
turning into a political lobbying group
that was set on reshaping the way
Americans thought about the Second
Amendment and making sure that no
legislation ever made it through that
curtailed gun rights they began pushing
an interpretation of the second
amendment that was about individual
protection a right to bear arms so that
you can protect yourself and trying to
deemphasize the connection to a
well-regulated militia as the purpose
for this right to bear arm in the face
of this Relentless onslaught of gun
control schemes you're the reason the
Second Amendment still stands you're the
tip of the spear you're the ones that
make it possible for us every day to
defend this freedom and it totally
worked the Second Amendment became more
and more a guarantee that everyone can
have guns to protect themselves and
their family having nothing to do with
protecting the country after all we had
the biggest military in the world we
didn't need a miltia anymore don't let
Hillary leave you protected with nothing
but a phone the NRA political Victory
fund is responsible for the content of
this advertising this interpretation of
guns and the Second Amendment would
become solidified in a 5 to4 vote in the
Supreme Court in 2008 when the Court
ruled that the Second Amendment
guaranteed people to have guns even when
those guns have no relationship to an
armed militia so this is why the United
States has more guns than any country on
Earth because the courts have ruled that
guns are an individual right a right to
bear arms every year 20,000 murders
occur with a gun
thousands of children and teens are
killed with a gun hundreds of deaths are
caused by gun accidents hundreds of mass
shootings and of course the leading
cause of gun violence suicides tens of
thousands of lives taken with guns but
we can't seem to do much about it
because as long as guns remain an
individual right now deeply woven into
American identity any effort to try to
pass reasonable laws to try to limit
these countless deaths that we have in
our country will continue to fail
especially as the NRA continues to
politicize guns to use them to divide
America to scare America and to make us
feel like we need guns to be safe the
facts are on our side guns save lives
and you'll never stop us from defending
our
[Music]
families my last visit was an important
one to this gun shop where the owner is
Swiss but as a card carrying member of
the NRA and a big fan of American Gun
culture I had to get his take on this
these are the best assault rifles in the
world really these are yes W what what
makes them so good why are they so good
there sis
mate any questions yeah yeah yeah
exactly you don't need to say
anymore what do you feel when you look
at American Gun
culture it's very very interesting uh
from the gun system from the gun law I
would like to live in the states but not
with all the dump asses
around I don't I don't know why there
are so many
um deaths mhm um accidents with Firearms
yeah and here nothing yeah I don't know
why why order do you sitting so stupid
and let a loaded firearm there on the
table with with kids 1 2 3 years old I
don't know why you need some room
some yeah you know our government they
support shooting clubs yeah they they do
support ammo they support shooting
ranges yeah they they support the guys
who are going to a shooting range you
need rules yeah you need to have it and
[Music]
yeah
so here's my conclusion in all of this I
went into this story thinking that I was
going to tell a policy story like how
different policies would affect gun
culture and it totally took a different
route because I learned sort of halfway
through that guns are a symbol they are
a symbol yes they're a weapon yes they
are a sports tool but they are also a
symbol for the people who wield them the
way we see guns is deeply influenced by
the stories and the myths of our
societies Switzerland and the United
States have two very different stories
and because of that they have two very
different gun cultures for Switzerland
having armed citizens who were trained
with weapons is what kept them neutral
and safe as a group as a collective the
United States admired this and tried to
copy it and they did for a while but
soon the demands of an expanding Empire
allowed that Vision to fade and turned
the meaning of guns into something
different making it a right for
individuals to protect themselves most
guns in America are not used to protect
people that's not what they're used for
they're often used at a shooting range
or hunting or to end someone's life and
yet to the people who hold fast to their
firearms as a right they feel like any
change to that any legislation to change
or to Li MIT to those guns is a taking
away of their right so the way I see it
as long as guns are an individual right
associated with personal protection and
personal Liberty Not A lot's going to
change in America we certainly don't
stand a chance of having a culture
anything like what we've seen here in
Switzerland and that's a shame to me
that's a
shame
[Music]
hey before you go I need to tell you one
last thing which is that we made proba
our last batch of the poster that I
designed last year it's a poster called
all maps are wrong and I'm very proud of
it it shows all the ways that you can
take our Earth and project it onto a 2d
plane which always comes with some
Distortion anyway it's kind of a nerdy
map lever thing and if you're into that
you should go over and check it out
before they're all gone this is probably
going to be our last batch so get them
while they last and uh the Link's in the
[Music]
description